[Musique]
je suis le représentant du peuple
algérien et aucune institution de la
république fut-elle l'armée nationale
populaire ne peut faire une bouchée de
moi mais je suis l'algérie tout entière
je suis l'incarnation du peuple algérien
alors dit aux généraux de morphée s'ils
peuvent le faire
les algériens s'apprêtent à voter pour
élire leur président le grand favori
reste bien sûr abdelaziz bouteflika âgé
de 77 ans il brigue un quatrième mandat
malgré ses origines
l'équipe fait ce film
pour l'achat
invisible pendant la campagne mais
omniprésent sur les murs d'alger
abdelaziz bouteflika n'arrive plus à se
déplacer seul attéby parent avait 5000
21 milliards de l'an et 9,6 en 2010 on a
qu'une raison d'un stérilet les
investissements les frites ennemi intime
attendus mi nahd et d'arômes 2010 la
campagne d'abdelaziz bouteflika va peut
être coûter jusqu'à 75 millions d'euros
et cela avec l'aide de nombreuses
entreprises privées amis mais selon
l'armée promet de veiller à sécuriser
avec force volonté et détermination ces
élections
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
va
tu peux pas avoir raison tout en
français parce que là j'ai tenté une
franchise qui la question est habile un
chiffre qui me paraît fiable pour les
militaires français environ castet
marathon et v6 france et environ 500
bien
500 pour ce qui concerne les français
pour cyclos qui concerne les français a
laissé bien su bien défendre et se
décompose
tu lis et noir sur blanc c'est du
français sa part du chinois la wallonie
à prendre un deuxième question
parisienne retrace ses archives
permettent de les identifier les
meilleurs ceux qui ont des français est
de comprendre logiquement prise et à
leur capture et par des français
ne parlent que dès que des prisonniers
français
alors alors il
n'y a pas de prisonniers algériens y a
pas de prisonniers
ont les exécuter je trouve quant à lui
beaucoup d'algériens qui servait hier et
me rattache bientôt reprendre la guerre
d'algérie france on était français
se disant algériens au départ c'est un
[Musique]
prisonnier américain
de la
serviette en discuter on est en train
d'en discuter de débattre d'autres
choses nos meilleurs dans l'optique des
choses on rattrape aussi des vaches le
soir avec pas dire que quand c'est fait
la journée c'est faire une journée
m bon et notre à notre premier la
première voiture atelier à saint dié
ouvrant on a pas de photos pour ce qu'on
veut en voir les chercher sur internet
entraînement en prenait pour ce qu'elle
photo d'une usine renault en mai s'est
encore accru
j'avais demandé meilleur changer quand
j'avais demandé une puce lively cela a
été fait
les nombres de déporter les écrans de
nourriture qu'il faut systématiquement
des mousses il faut systématiquement des
anglais qui consiste à systématiquement
avec la d'économistes il fera beau sais
pas
[Applaudissements]
si tu compagnie pas de vous je suis
tenté de dire c'est bien de
développement on va il a besoin d'un
public pas même
c'est irréaliste convient avec cette
campagne je suis complètement
con avoue réfléchir la même d'autres
sujets
mais
c'est l'imagination qui rend facile à
pardonner aux enfants suis quand même
allé de risque qui a su convaincre un
des rois il est fait des propositions
aussi en économie
quand il apparaît une croissance de 7%
il tomber c'est une pauvre et c'est bien
de le dire mais c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
entendu un chiffrage comme ça suit un
lieu dans les tournois je me laissais
sont bien dommage que ceci sera ma
prétendue tout ça na li bin ali benflis
par rapport aux autres il a quand même
fait des propositions politiques par
exemple y parle pas mais continue antoni
maria et tout ça il faut remettre le
conseil de la magistrature sur
l'autorité d'un magistrat élu
contrairement aux oscars pas moi je
pense qu'il a déclinée quand même une
espèce de fait de l'autre pas fou le
modifier mais par rapport à l'autre
encore il ya la question qui se pose est
ce que vous ne laisserez capable
vraiment de déjouer les pronostics en
appel en mai sur ma conscience et puis
c'est que oui mon abandon en accordant
les fêtes probablement mais en réalité
ce qui nous intéresse c'est l'histoire
des deux étoiles n'en parle pas mais je
ne vois pas comment vous tue d'état va
passer au premier tour c'est ça ne va
pas arrêter les scénarii 2004 tony de
son milieu et puis c'est pas sérieux
distinctif chez free c'est que là il est
les en attaque frontale mois
tequila dès qu'il a été attaqué aussi la
balle et postés de manière violente
il disait que moi j'en ai même pas
d'avoir famille à la présidence il parle
de 2 cette api qui est gérée par la
corruption ne sous-estimons pas les
l'importance de crédit qui sont donnés à
70 opérateurs ça se
c'est bien il y a le jeune artiste
retina et ces gens là il sera fourni les
prendre cet argent en espèce
n'avait rien à voir avec les impôts ce
n'est que moi avant projet d'une
entreprise de travaux publics ou de
canalisations etc etc je suis en
je suis en bonne relation avait trouvé
pour la série et c'est dans des ordres à
ça se passe comme ça tu meurs ça se
passe comme ça il faut qu'on la voit ça
fait passer le plus beau des
financements on me demande de crédit
considérable considérable et puis une
partition par jean jeu je retire de la
banque en espèces et puis je le mets à
ces mesures il faut qu'on aborde c'est
parce qu'il a cette fois ci dans cette
campagne c'est ce qui nous a dit un
autre jour
c'est ce que beaucoup de gens disent
actuellement des économistes il faut qu'
il faut qu'on fasse sûr que ça nous
donne un jeune et plus loin une très
bonne partie de cet argent va les voir
dans les poches des individus
dans les poches des individus à sodexo
s'est même par ensuite dépenser comme
dans des métiers
c'est un vrai gisement de certains
individus
santos mais il faut pas qu'on oublie que
vous attendez de manquer ça c'est une
quarante ans
en attaque il que ces constitutions en
avance
avec avec ce mois en berne bien que le
sauver
ma place est
allée on se met au boulot comme un
[Musique]
son
de passer
[Musique]
on
pour
c'est tout le monde
reconnaît que le régime a recruté même
parmi la jeunesse et beauté dans sa mort
est tout ça il va recruter je suis je
suis déçu de devenir mais maintenant ces
deux partis pas de vous je pensais pas
non mais c'est pas grave tu sais que le
réseau doit rentrer mais tu sais que le
fln s'il est stable depuis 62 sont
menées par establie est complet en
kabylie là dans chaque commune de
cabinet et au patient il attend à chaque
élection en kabylie site des élections
transparentes qu'on ne peut pas frauder
là bas il ya toujours des élus de faire
le lit de riz si tout le monde est la
suivante le monde s'y attendait viellard
tout le monde quand tu deviens à temps
passe et un discours dont je me
contentais largement teintées sont tous
les autres non je dis c'est celle où il
acheté beaucoup de temps mais il n'a pas
parce que
je suis en hd qu'ils ont acheté des
biens succès mais n'était jamais bien su
bien secrète un système que l'on dise
c'est fou c'est un fonds d'épargné c'est
un trou noir me demandant tout le monde
et on sera
moi je te dis que tu vois que tu
as l'habitude de donner raison là c'est
parce qu'aujourd'hui juste envers le
biais j'ai juste envie de vielles
d'aménagement dans les couches sociales
comment il allait manquer décalage mais
je suis largement dotées d'un contre
bien quand j'estime à combien la wii
triste maladie cérébrale moi c'est un
samedi par la majorité très largement si
ça je ne peux pas dire parce que 67 %
des objets
contredit les
figures parce que eux ils savent qu'une
à lui quand même depuis tout le temps
elle élections dans ce pays n'a pas de
sens que le gluten de votre n'a aucun
sens sont 92 les gens ont voté à 92 les
gens ont voté plus ou moins massivement
leur a dit non vous avez fait un mauvais
choix d'accord c'est vous qui décidez
votre part vous faites ce que vous
voulez prétention de nous on ne peut pas
rester comme ça il ya 11 ans dans la
société c'est pas statique ça ça bouge
dans tous les sens je pense qu'à la fin
elle ne bouge pas nécessiter bouge
landon dont on en oublie et on n'hésite
à stalinien l'association s'est
installée chez nous pas de bouchon à six
semaines de préparation en attendant
2011 on a recensé pas moins de 1500
mouvement dans la social sais pas mais
c'est pas aux politiques 5% d'algérie
n'a peut-être rien petit bout qui bouge
dans à porter goss je veux dire parce
que quand je dis rouge bout parce qu'il
sait ils sont ils sont venus par par une
arrière pensée politique ils veulent
faire changer les choses tu vois mais
son talent qui bouge il bouge pour la
bouffe il bouge de choses
pourquoi ce crime sioniste
[Musique]
au juste le dire je fais de ton
dynamisme
d'un bon plat d'intermédiation sociale
il y a une foi et des partis politiques
oui une feuille des partis politiques et
sur l'espace avait le pouvoir de pouvoir
les partis critiquent manga fait
[Musique]
chez les poissons mais je ne vais pas de
bouger de faire des mythes et des dents
dehors des scrutins des élections des
partis politiques
je suis tentée de tous les partis
politique qui complaît pas de pouvoir
d'ailleurs ne bouge pas a laissé son
service est vrai ou pas vrai alors quand
tu fais pas cet effort de médiation
sociale quant aux biens par exemple une
école qui a fermé le parti politique
c'est ma vocation naturelle je vais voir
le directeur je vais parler aux enfants
et je vais je vais politiser cette
affaire c'est très bon et c'est de bonne
guerre mais ils ne font rien du tout je
ne suis pas satisfait je parle avec un
sur un ton très grave parce que je suis
quand même déçu pour mon pays mais
malheureusement c'est la triste réalité
quand quand vous dira tout dit ou la
scène elle te dis sorti un peu d'alger
pour moi c'est pierre nous sortir un peu
votre soutien
attention même si certains ça fait pas
plaisir j'ai pas angie qui décide quand
tu vois qu'elle fait les gens te disent
oui par amateurs du ccaf nous il ya des
gens qui pensent que c'est pour nos
co-présidents
attention
oui oui j'ai peur la télévision des
genres ici le travail que j'ai écouté ça
à la télévision algérienne il y avait un
problème c'est qu'ils sont à mille
lieues des savoirs hadj alouane y avoir
quand tu pendant le terrain je pouvais
te dit c'est quoi ce papa les supporters
dans ce qu il sait pas c'est pas fatras
mattei 62 dans la révolution et tout ça
il faut il faut bien faire quand il faut
conscientiser les gens défendent la
politique solange et de sabotage et
aussi ce soit les gens font de la
politique s'organise et prend à chaque
fois qu'ils s'organisent en or voilà la
police la dépression
tu te pas dit que je voulais partager ni
je fais quand je viens d'attraper les
jeux c'est score les gens s'intéressent
à la politique on les empêche de faire
la politique oui les empêche de
s'organiser pour cent d'une guerre
civile qui a cassé le ressort de la
société dit inquiet que je fais n'est
pas mon ami tu ne sais pas c'est
l'avenir c'est unique fourni qu'un seul
nom tous ces révisions application une
explication pour l'année pas discuter
seulement
je ne peux pas comprendre peut-être
c'est la mythique histoire du cac mais
bien sûr
c'est une qualité mais bien évidemment
mais bien évident c'est une gas lift est
historique c'est des contradictions qui
font avancer des sociétés
je n'appelle pas
mal
vous êtes trompés théologie c'est messi
qui choisit audiologie ambitieux qui
fabriquons les projets à fort il ne
l'est pas
c'est pour ça que tu n'y es tu le joues
un bien cette idéologie cette nouvelle
idéologie qui est le bien le mal c'est
par l'insee mais si c'est un
jeu d'enfant
mais moi je dirais que c'est pas mal la
laïcité ne m'intéresse pas j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi j'ai donné ce jeudi matin moi
je ne pense pas le monde a pas lieu de
20 km mais voilà comme je parle je sors
juste envie de dire que la laine des
affaires publiques elles ne sont pas
elles ne montrent pas les gérer par les
gens parce que dans la cité il ya plus
de religion il ya de la religion aussi
qu'on veut qu'on ne peut réussir ce
n'est pas sa part dit loi connais la
mort de son petit ami de reposer leurs
différents donc fait en un mois mais si
ici mais si ça moi j'accepte qui ont
accepté pas si j'avais 18 ans
je ne peux pas me donner peut-être le
bon pour moi moi moi je dirais seulement
mieux c'est pour ça qu'on a inventé la
démocratie
que on peut
bien dire mais est-ce que honey moon est
fondamentalement différent - mais est-ce
qu'on peut partager des choses c'est
bien celle là
mais le seul problème c'est lui il est
là il dispute cette info n'est pas si tu
vas nature apprendre tout ce qui s'est
passé par là mais c'est pas ça qui fixe
la bagnole de ton à notre de ton
interview si toi tu me poserai pas une
question s'est enflé et il est voilà les
questions que je sois persuadé qu'ils
sont liés à sa deuxième de la seconde
intervention je le pense plus je
passerai sur la mer
et
remis à temps hélas il
n'a pas été percutant nonsensique les
façons je vais jouer mais je pense pas
vraiment
plus tôt mais le mont choisy
mais n'a pas choisi
je conviens que s'est dit déçu mais bien
sûr aussi
c'est plutôt le jeu qui a dans la france
est elle elle précise et passait sa
pensée
depuis vendredi soir je vis dans
l'angoissé a soutenu essayer de mettre
carrément le
soir que visibles
les gens se bousculent visage
allait
marquer
voilà les récepteurs conciliation
concilier c'était pas ça
je te reprocher la prière
de repenser l'avenir quoi
[Musique]
on
j'avais les jambes au terme de combats
qui ne voient plus
i
saw les sélectionne le public les a
mollo c'est bien les spas adjoint
quesnoy le
sauve batum liberté l'homme après
casquette entre la promesse d'une
subvention pour les associations
il m'a dit que non ça tout comme les
maisons des raisons pourquoi les
candidats choisis sur certains endroits
je prendrais sans spécifiquement le
faire annonce que j'ai compris que le
match
s'est
qualifié non saisie par la pertinence de
faire l'ouverture c'est elle c'est un
détail dans un parfum n'a pas le choix
quand on a des scénario se situe à
comprendre parce que la seule chose qui
l impertinence et c'est le forcing des
représentants du candidat mais ils ont
essaimé un peu partout mentionné la
limite ça je pense que ça c'est un angle
les gens des gens qui mal qu'ils sont
prêts à voter vous devez pas ils veulent
continuer famille même souffle il ya que
lui qui à cet effet sur les foules
rennes c'est le temps et m'ont
fait mal à vous lasser l'idée que la
scène pendant les phases amont pour
faire remplacer le président et on voit
que c'est ils sont empêtrés dans leurs
déchets unis déjà sur facebook à une
théorie les six candidats à des crises
un candidat défendra dans les boutiques
la réponse est oui exactement c'est
n'importe quoi après il ya d'autres
aspects
ces convois y ait autant de monde donc
autant d'huile avait en même temps moi
je me pose une question sur le court
parce que ils sont en tant que monde de
la personne comparer le proxy d'agents
publics ces salaires ne me connaissaient
pas et n'ont pas le droit de faire de
l'argent public donc ça aussi c'est
maintenant ça veut dire que on reste sur
le don du week du big heat et du
président qui est en toi qui t'es voir
le président fantôme arrivera pas là
sans histoire sans être la france est un
très bon très bien merci comme une
décision concernant
moi je t'ai donné qu'une page ou leurs
15 très bien et je voulais savoir ce que
tu veux avait suffisamment de matière ou
un maigre chante pas que c'est parfait
j'ai une belle photo par contre je sais
qu'ils ont une les agressions
écoute j'ai une petite photo que
j'aimerais bien que tu m'attends dans
l'exacte c'était petits enfants atteints
du cancer qui ont été aux l'association
est mais les a pris pour des vaches pour
les vacances en haut à paris
orly 10 à disneyland voilà donc
j'aimerais bien que tu place la faute à
bavay et environs une petite information
mon bar avec une photo on la met au val
donc si tu veux mettre tout ça en valeur
des sites est maintenant de 6 dans le
four civile side alors
dans une
c'est la honte
une sens de l'honneur ni le centre du
droit de l'année ma dignité et puis elle
ressemble tellement sage de traînards
quand ils te dis que c'est beau la mafia
italienne et plus respectables 2e mais
je suis obligé de continuer parce que
vous me l'avez demandé malgré ma santé
c'est comme celle qui sait qu'il vient
de nommer personne
le sondage est une référence dans mes
yeux
une autre quatrième
c'est ce qu'il a dit un médecin pour ma
belle soeur elle a été le voit mieux dit
puisqu'on va voter pour les morts moi je
vais voter pour vous me dire
10 puisque la porte le rapport louis
mais absent donc on votait pas pour
bondy mont blanc
puisque j'aime beaucoup bull dire
je me suis dit tu m'as
jamais trop tôt ses dernières flèches
notre abri des tas les cinq candidats
ont tous fui en brousse et e mais il y
aura plein de boutons tours 2-0 ombre
parce qu'on doit être de chacun mène sa
campagne ils sont 15 litres irakiennes
leur absence à
6,6106 l'actu de ces trois
là ont la place de lucho à c'est
quelqu'un qui a un masque qui est le
masque vénitien
on essaie ça qu'on s'est tous les
candidats sans raison avec
[Musique]
sa voûte étoilée personnes et fiat y
aura plein de personnes combat et voilà
qu'elle rachetait avec les races de
moutons je suis rendu un jugement pour
cette
république à machin chouette ministère
des finances fonds national
d'investissement
oh
double zéro oui 300
638 30 g 2 vas-y composants 300
jeux pour alès manière comme g
double
0,300
1638 et jettera j'ai
compris
tu veux pas pas sur mac on entend les
verra pas elle sera à dounia carter je
préfère pas que ce soit en a pas on ne
rentre pas dans le bâti suis l'un
des deux blessés
parce qu'avec ta le diabète j'y vais
c'est une maman je la laisse avec un
entretien
mais les belles filles et le bon fils
c'est pas la même chose des belles
finales a et c'est pour toi c'est leur
mari
de la
[Musique]
reine elizabeth
lamari ce qu'on avait pensé que ma vie
peut-être qu'il a marié une seule fille
ah oui marie
son a produit 10
oui
[Musique]
moi je veux pas dire des chefs d'état
étrangers qui n'a pas l'étoffé les
choisis par son peuple
[Musique]
mais
je suis vraiment demandé par la défense
du continent mais après il est sorti
avec 25% mais sauf que ce mystique je
suis à me casser la milca qui ont élu
georges bush l'ont bien compris
il faut donner le risque qu'elle soit
sur l'intelligence n'est pas plus grave
elles sont par exemple même si le très
cher même si j'insiste pour dire que
françois hollande
on
commence à les collectionner
est-ce qu'on peut facilement mesure apte
à l'est d'alger je pense que je vais
attendre que même certains nombre
d'éclairages sur la place qui est
absolument
millions d'écus t elle dans le monde
arabe donc s'ils essayent de sortir de
ce fait les cannois et le soudan il fait
papier
si ce n'est pas la tunisie il sait ils
sont tous aussi un jeu pour revenir aux
mollahs il a sur le dos de la mission
dit les lra l'egypte le koweït là où je
vais pas pourrait tirer profit de cette
visite même si géopolitique mois ils
sont pas d'accord c'est que le matin
annonce un plan d'investissement dans
les 5000 comme il l'a fait au maroc
finalement c'est pour y remédier il peut
faire ça donc les gens dont dix ans
après tu vois il ya des gens qui
proposent en effet de cette annonce pour
paribas gagné on est des gens qui
marchaient dans les tractations en
effet aussi comment le régime le groupe
incite au ciel pour les fructifier cette
visite voilà j'ai l'impression d'aller
apprendre moi j'aimerais bien exemple en
transférant sur cette visite qui ne
vient pas comme moi même jour que celle
de kelly est ce que on le disait en ce
sens est ce que il y aura mon contrat
j'allais dire
a320 magenta est ce que terrible et deux
éducateurs au delà des questions qui
agitent une vie dû confondre les
différents et compliqua et complétion de
questions
duprat la banlieue ont déchiqueté rien
pour toi tout ça est ce que pour ce qui
nous concerne à julie il ya un homme
agents tapoter rim et le qatar hommage
et même s'il ya une opposition d'
approche par rapport à ce qui se passe
dans le monde arabe l'émir du qatar et
la vie et la famille beaucoup plus tôt
que tout la prairie l'ami de la famille
ok c'est bon le supplément bagages et on
a un sujet sur la fameuse vidéo terre
les propos de l'etrat les artistes on
est parti voir les artistes pour savoir
quelles étaient leurs motivations et
tout ça tapera leur épargner le bon
choix il est comme ça rassure
littéralement mais je dis oui bien sûr
c'est un homme je veux dire quand même
et il c'est quelqu'un qui fut le choix
de vivre ailleurs d'un point de vue moir
il n'a pas de nous ingérer n'a pas faire
compagne pour un tel ou tel candidat il
a choisi de s'établir au maroc de
d'avoir une seconde nationalité si
devenu pratiquement monnaies courantes
pour aider les artistes fellaghas a
choisi de dépendants de sécurité
françaises lui la nationalité la galerie
des terreaux n'a
par exemple ce que j'adhère à 10h
flagrant j'ai ramené manière franche oui
mais je veux dire certaines autorisent
c'est un fait il ya des gens beaucoup
d'artistes beaucoup d'artistes ont pris
la tangente durant les années de la
dgrad et puis avec un plus tard imaginez
un instant fait mal il prend position
pour des quartiers
sensibles en matière de biens de luxe et
pagnol et ils sont sur le terrain
politique qui sont plus artiste ça pose
problème
ces cas une panne de
design est sympa mais en fait sur
youtube du petit
impressions des gens qui chantent un
taux d'emploi global et maintenant paris
km est
assez particulier parce qu'il ya dans la
rédaction d'el watan il ya des
sensibilités sur la question du sahara
occidental par rapport au maroc c'est
une réalité on peut pas décrire les
sensibilités particulières et lui il a
mis là c'est l'ami s'affiche à chaque
fois c'est l'ami de loi il est paraît il
la chantait laâyoune là que les lions de
l'atlas marocain dont nous énervait sous
il y avait une idée dans un avis ou les
organisations internationales
les ingénieurs var et puis maintenant il
vient être au dessus de tout
ça pas sans poser problème surtout à
l'ail il faut peut-être accompagné sa
demande et celle
en avant
tu sais pourquoi je soutiens les rares
mais laquelle le groupe
étudie parce que depuis que moody's a
fait agent mois du whisky
voilà c'est là qu'ils m'ont politique
de
fait il est venu assister à un concert
de cheval
moi je dis pas déjà le titre a déjà
quelques idées au logis c'était
peut-être et américains virology tu
crois que tu portes beaulieu est d'abord
là
que viennent que vient d'émerger
patronne lui parce que par contre c'est
pas stratégiquement ses paniers de la
fin du régime support géopolitique on
est très différents des positions lui
quand il dit qu il serait que amis et
lui par contre préféré à tort recevoir
sur leur promettre qu'ils ouvrent sucre
et étant en examen apparemment il
n'arrive à rien en deux fois qu'il est
enfant il a dit non il ce soir contre
les hells qui était venue pour l'ue
avertit radieux j'ai commandé deux qu'il
est on est venu pour exactement 13
heures le tas ce soir on n'a pas fait un
bisou 9 mai les différents terminaux
les huit premières fois qu'il ya un tel
exercice qu'une arme de flamandisation
ambiance à l'égard
saturés des contenus la libye le mali
la tunisie j'ai fait tout ça est ce que
j laisser le pays entre dans la région
là une aberration mentale à des défis
colossaux donc elle peut il faut lui
faire
on va commencer ce que tu portes bien
sûr le qatar suisse depuis la boutique
atteint
deux tiers
jean torrent
neuf sur la génétique
des expériences uniques tous les autres
sauf qu'il ya un petit souci c'est que
les enjeux ne sont pas au courant que la
situation économique au venezuela est
désastreux ces salles pour comprendre et
entendre expliqué dans why
on va faire un chapeau on va expliquer
tout ça on avait les yeux là
c'est pas évident c'est pas
de titre et agréable à il aimait
il renvoie pas automatiquement
à une situation difficile la photo
le pillage de pillage des magasins
pendant les émeutes la sillage des
malécites oui tout à fait après un beau
chapeau d'explication c'est là il ya
maintenant ce qu'on appelle le syndrome
venezuela
maintenant dissipateur sort si je sais
pas faire que des changements non
ailleurs selon ce rapport on a des
séparatistes au réseau local si l'asie
est ce que vous avez fait un bon choix
avant dans ses bagages
qui jongle
qui parce qu'ils passent allègrement
bien
comment voyez vous l'évolution de la
diplomatie est dû cet imam
qui pratiquent
diplomatie du chéquier
comment voyez vous l'évolution nationale
qui pratiquera diplomatie du chéquier
alors abandonner
ma fille
enfin
[Musique]
oh
c
pratiquement de cinq mois sont grises
troisième est un jeune homme
m
lens portier
le choix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais l'avenir
du jeu
[Musique]
[Rires]
balligand à l'ehpad et corps à
l'extérieur
safer
tu as vu là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la politique
c'est
pourquoi on rejette élections parce
qu'elle est fermée si tu dis que les
chefs vous apprêter les joué d'avancé
pourquoi en avant des dix huit et dix
ans contre
quatre il ya des groupuscules qui
appartient à la tête d'autres pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
moi je pense que c'est un pays où il ya
une beaucoup de manipulations s'est
spontanément les vitraux moi j'ai dit
que mon fils dans l'ordre à ses
partisans de faire ça
les gens attendaient la venue de suède
pour exprimer leur rejet de ce quatrième
mandat qui est vécu un nouveau
partenaire population une commune pauvre
elles sont au milieu et face à face à
face à la police qu'eric a réagi
inévitablement ça va ça va tourner
à l'affrontement à l'émeute jean pierre
bade je pense qu'il ya des choses que
l'on se raconte à tout le monde quant à
pierre barthas une caméra ou l'attaqué
ou journalistes mais c'est vrai que le
pouvoir à travers le traitement de ce
qui s'est passé hier un traitement mais
des titres ce qui s'est passé hier mais
j'ai senti une volonté d une volonté de
se la victimisation tué la victime valve
nous on évoquera si voilà mais attendez
quand tu réfléchis bien si finalement le
pouvoir qui est en pays dont au moins
huit ou dix wilayas selon le nôtre est
cependant se place il n'a pas tenu ce
genre de discours et pense que les jeux
mais la ville et cetera pour la prépa c
est pas des chemins des désoeuvrés etc
et disait qu'il y avait une tension dans
l'air c'est à dire que
[Musique]
la part pour assassin ya un ras-le-bol
la mode est peut-être que les gens
considèrent elles saluent la candidature
du quatrième mandat est une forme de
violence qui a maintenant parce que deux
compagnes elle accuse nommément les
boycotter est-ce que les fronts du
boycott est-ce que jusqu'à présent il ya
eu des actes de violence dans tout les
magasins qu'ils ont fait est-ce qu'il ya
texte politique où ils font du chalutage
des meetings une stratégie je ne pense
pas que l'appel sur facebook pour
nettoyer la ville selon les bougiotes
ils disent on va on va nettoyer la ville
pour aller trouver au
gouvernement on aime nos jeans et les
purs ce qui s'est passé ne sera pas
récupéré
aujourd'hui cette question est ce qu'on
fait payer par des spécialistes a en
fait demandé le journaliste de
surprendre ceux qui à l'intérieur on
reste factuel comme enjeu aujourd'hui la
ville de béjaïa est aujourd'hui et à
côté décryptage de ce qui s'est passé
elle veut faire parler si je me suis
ceux qui sont accusés
d'exactions
sur moi je pense qu'on a des qualités
pratiques de bougies
la question vous avez identifié des gens
est ce que les partis politiques
implantées dans la région comme son père
bonne lisibilité de ce père et gendre
avantage factuel plus en faveur des
clips parce qu'ils seront pris en charge
par le biais
danse acrobatique et des jackets
comprenez pas ce qu'ils ont fait fuir à
dubaï je ne dois pas qu'on n'a plus à
faire le jeune homme y fit sentir
politique peut louer tu viens de
commencer à faire il contient de
très
puissant je n'ai jamais caché que je
peux travailler pour les loyaux ils ont
atterri ce débat nous devons condamner
tout ça et ça s'arrête là saleh tandis
que les parts à cannes elle a
malheureusement pas pourquoi
ça se produit
d'accord
mercier
non
une fois voilà ce que j'attends
c'est cette nouvelle flambée de violence
armée sont affrontés et plusieurs
policiers
je prêche ben moi je le dis en diagonale
que je donnerai tout à les regarder
les cadets sont
présents moi je fais confiance à collias
une fois un truc maintenant est-ce que
des mots avec son patin aussi j'ai pas
dit ça mais j'ai pas dit ça
c'est sûr non je sais pas dire moi je
sais pas c'est qu'elle n'est pas sur
place je passe je suis pas même pas qui
lui a envoyé le papier d'angle et
envoyer la formation
canadienne c'est lui qui signe un
week-end au
quotidien
faut il faut il faut qu'il nous fasse la
liste des correspondants suspect ne
paraît
on peut aujourd'hui
proposer une ouverture à travers tout ce
qui a été dit ce matin et maintenant
disons que finalement vous ne voulez pas
ce n'est plus l'ombre de l'instabilité
mais l'homme de la division
internationale le début benflis il a
réussi à mobiliser sur sortie mille
hommes
pour surveiller tous les bureaux de vote
et à 23 heures il aura les résultats
vers l'innovation proclamé président
quelques jours il se confirme ils vont
sur programming président président est
le légitime je ne sais d'où friis il va
se proclamer président viendra retirer
son voile et versa
s'il est battu à la loyale il ya la
chanteuse 28 en arrière maintenant
signes laissent ils pensent qu'il est
les délais il dira j'ai été élu qui va
se proclamer président
tu as en face une foule qui ne se fasse
qui encourage
enfin biais à se faire c'est l'algérie
s'est rajeuni sa le présentation des
différentes ong s'étaient ravisés mais
son corps est en colère avec en lançant
des bottes de concerts des tomates et
des outs et cela aussi ils sont preneurs
ce qui justifiera d'axa le titre vous
devrez pas divise les algériens seraient
là c'est une division
cela commande montre et portsmouth les
rames de type tower
la chaise roulante est abordée notamment
tonnes au lieu que ce soit 1,30 à un jeu
le césar le sait pas qui c'est sa chaise
roulante c'est que ça c'est symbolique
c'est à dire que c'est un monarque
important je ne peux pas continuer mais
entre temps avec son entêtement de
vouloir forcer le passage parce que là
c'est un passage qu'ils vont essayer de
forcer ben
là ça ça rejoint un peu d'outils très en
verve année c'est indécent qui doit
tenter inscrit ce site intitulé
690 m
[Musique]
c
oh
on
[Musique]
oh
je pense pas bien fait
à
mes amis
ml
travail ça sinon vraiment
travailler
avant ça
ça finit sa finesse a que ça fait rêver
les sacrés finissant quelques combats
avaient travaillé avec
deux matches ici faudra vraiment que
thomas doret ici aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
nous travaillons
aujourd'hui bravo au travail notre mais
mon mari dit demandera aujourd'hui
travail oit au travail aujourd'hui me
faire opérer après moi je serais pas ici
ok
[Musique]
la chanson
sera
présenté le 16 janvier halte à
vous
[Musique]
de changer d'entraîneur je suis alors ne
vous gêne pas c'est un super joueur
[Musique]
les télévisions numériques nous n 3
mondial chez toi bourguiba
inégaux
coulaines
91 34 gardes je viens de me voler ma vie
dans ma ville de fort qui me donne que
tous les parlements gober
maintenant 40 ans toutes deux n'a pas
son calme et la sagesse ou même des
firmes à 20 h toujours à tous et à
toutes de purs est
mou tout art ou 12
[Musique]
connais tu vends donc s'expliquer en
expansion des fantômes il a peur de
sortir une piste en herbe tu serais
beaucoup de joueurs qui veulent sortir
dans la rue le portugal font part donc
là tu poses la communauté un petit
tracteur des matisse et manifestations
il ya une atmosphère de colère qui était
fait du vol ensuite on revient aux
origines aux origines et à l'école
l'arabisation
talal
la terrifie instrumentalisés par le
pouvoir exécutif
c'est le matraquage la propagande
politique c'est l'abrutissement quelque
part dans des programmes qui est en fait
à chaque fois je fais allusion au texte
à vous qu'on limite parle de dé des
programmes qui font appel à l'affect à
l'émotion du monde où tout est en train
de la d'empêcher de penser l'algérie n'a
rien d'un pas pressé d'en manger dormir
mais peut-être que
non je vais devoir penser peut-être que
marre et on serait tenté d'emballer
moyens par contre je suis prudent non je
suis prêt non parce que je pose une
question au départ et je suscite
un petit peu ça le rend problématique
après un moment le but c'est de soulever
des barrages et pas n'importe pas eu de
réponse
désolé pour chiffrer ce désamour et ceux
qui le soutiennent donnant suite à des
commentaires bon je vois pas les biens
mais bien après tout bien ça j'ai pris
pour exemple le mouvement ballack est
de 3 min qui est à la direction de
campagne de routes et d'écoles qui les
traite de fasciste est-ce que c'est pas
d'habilitation ce mouvement parce qu'il
est juste sortir dans la rue à des
pancartes
/
du côté des recettes faciles et puis a
levé l'état d'urgence est en droit la
constitution les berges sont en droit de
mettre de manifester pour rentabiliser
salut fasciste dit kylie kylie
assentiment de la droite il ya un
sentiment de révolte ou basique mais il
ya entretenues ici en fait de la révolte
elle venait pas requis par les
syndicalistes les intellectuels des
opposants politiques étudiants ils
abritent voilà des mois que suppose de
transport
évidemment auquel cas il serait injuste
de dire que les gens ne sont pas
conscients de ce que oui
bon après y'a deux formes nouvelles
structures et ça c'est des syndicats
ces gens qui entreprennent des actions
de rue ou de grève comme quoi les
algériens ont du mal à se révolter
pourquoi d'invention avancement est ce
que c'est cette façon décoiffé de
l'europe ou de soumettre le peuple
bonjour est dit ou fait une révolte
parce que bon parce qu'il ya révolte à
mon sens il ya révolte dans les esprits
il y a les indices une révolte depuis
2011 stade et aimante et à des
manifestations et pourtant et pourtant
il n'y a pas d'eau de rebâtir de
révolution
event
en attendant c'est tuer dans l'oeuf quoi
étouffer
dans l'oeuf non tu sais avant même que
le
dans covert [__] à la base
je souhaite un prêteur des boules quiès
la bad ce qui se passe avec les
promoteurs pourraient si jamais voté
c'est à dire la baie
de boycotteurs
les candidats chacun suivis candidat
quand tu vois ça c'est dire ça ces
classements les pages
c'est un gain de temps
je veux une version pas
hélas le poids
je suis
marois
liberté
liberté prochain que le soir
on pas vu ça c'est pour ça qu'on doit
pas nous avons refusé un contrat avec la
marine le chantage aux nous avons décidé
de mettre fin au chantage on ne soyons
plus de quatre heures avec un dock n'a
pas de relation contractuelle annette et
puis il ya un système pluraliste système
démocratique des systèmes ouverts de
compétition
l'octroi de leurs publicités obéir au
tirage au bio ici comme en france
et
à
des situations de diversité d'expression
ça décolle compteur des journaux
représentent une pensée ou le présente
un point de vue qui est minoritaire et
qui le journal ambition n'a pas des
moyens financiers de maintenir à flot
7,7 line ce sont des instruments
construit sur l'institutionnel si
l'assemblée nationale informatique et
octroie chaque année à l'humanité qui
est un journal que le présente une
sensibilité un budget qui voterez pas
l'ensemble et l'absence de limitation
chez nous permet au colonel avant drs
aujourd'hui que l'on est de la dcn à
cette thématique de la revue peut faire
un bond aussi aujourd'hui et c'est
peut-être l'occasion
avec ce que vivent certains journaux bon
ils sont le droit de changer de ligne de
ne plus retourner couturier pas voilà il
paie
jacques pas sûr
[Musique]
je voulais te vois pour le pouvoir de
tout toutes les affaires qui sont en
instance notamment la dernière a fait de
l'humour on a été condamnée à dix et le
1 million d'inhaler et son mille dinars
chacun avec joe g à d pour la chronique
bon moi je suis scandalisé quand il fait
pas recette cette condamnation parce que
c'est une convention qui n'est pas juste
voici un wali qui arrivent à condamner
un journal dans sa propre willaya dans
ses propres juridictions un million de
l'immeuble le nous avons continué à
plaider que la caricature et le billet
la colonie ce sont des genres
journalistiques qui sont différents de
l'enquète la liberté de la presse c'est
le sait la liberté de faire des enquêtes
fouillées avec des documents des preuves
lorsqu'on met en cause une institution
ou une personnalité là on a obligation
d'apporter des preuves mais le
commentaire est libre la chronique et le
dessin sondés sont des gens
journalistique ce sont des des pratiques
journalistiques qui sont dans le monde
très accepté je sais nous on n'accepte
pas que un chroniqueur puisse se donner
la liberté de 2,2
là quand tu le disiez la dérision de
pousser paraît loin ma démission
l'absence de loi fait que le ministère
public qui est un démembrement de
l'exécutif entend agir en pleine liberté
pour condamner poursuivre fonctionner
mieux que ça elle essaie de freiner la
création journalistique fondu de
l'activité gens d'ici que l'on respire
tout à fait
le journaliste est pénalisé par la loire
elle ne le défends pas elle ne prend pas
en charge sa quête de vérité mais mieux
que ça l'administration ne livre pas la
part d'informations qu'elle a pour aider
le journaliste à soir de manière
correcte une bonne enquête nous avons
beau attendre taper sur la table
téléphoner vaccins etc parfois nous
allons dans des tribunaux diminué parce
que l'administration refusé de compléter
l'enquète
quand il s'agit de relations avec
l'autorité l'autorité publique
l'autorité politique les juges de vienne
caresse avec il ne comprend bien donc
beaucoup de dossiers on a beau apporter
des preuves il ya ni fils a dit qu'il ya
une condamnation
à moment donné je conseille la race
la race page a les moyens d'affronter
une équipe pour la faire l'armée même la
remise des prix ne ressent
pas c'est la première fois que d'origine
on se permet de tirer comme ça dans la
presse
française
tel mandat de dépôt par le pousser au
pourrissement
facilement cela nous sommes entrain de
large et est bien rangé
d'accord ce marché gentil c'est une
hémorragie
c'est
vous
hamdoulilah
ce qui doit être mis en valeur c'est un
peu les personnages
c'est celle d'amd qui a key à la plage
fermée et la dimension émotionnelle
voilà c'est comme ça on s'en fout de ce
qui est écrit on s'en fout des pancartes
on s'en fout c'est dit dans le doigt
dans le pot 4 avec nous à nous exprimer
l'idée générale jean son premier
bond à baraka et ferrer on a préféré
mettre en valeur les ministres vont
épuiser tous les gens qui les gens en
terrasse ou dans la série d'idées je
n'entends pas référence à mouvement
je peux rien dire la science n'a pas
fait parler du lien je suis dans
l'obligation de réserve
donc je vais déjà pas mal de plus après
on est celle de laon 3 83e
[Musique]
contrat
ensuite des compagnies passage
[Musique]
une leçon
tous
[Musique]
nous
utilisions
la force de marquer les discussions
communautaires pour moi le processus de
parole que les avions n'avaient après la
probable et à se parler pour moi c'est
sa vague et je termine sur soi disant
nous ne sont pas pressés nous ne sont
pas du tout prêts ce moi ça me gêne pas
du tout bon je vais faire une confidence
après le vin ne serait pas intéressant
cru moi j'avais partir à la présidence
j'ai compris devant moi dieu et pour moi
je n'ai pas attendre que 37 millions
d'algériens
réagissent à 0 la citoyenneté c'est
d'abord un truc perso d'après moi qui
décide en son âme et conscience de
prendre monde et seront pas de me
prendre un chien donc nous
il se trouve qu'on a eu
on s'est retrouvé dans un comté soit en
été on a partagé un volet les mêmes
craintes et nos angoisses et aussi les
notre espoir et c'est un dieu mais
comment la vie comme gandhi le canada on
s'inscrit dans l'après on n'est pas très
serré on va bien sûr travail sur la
proximité willy colonna british
avec un autre ben oui y'a l'année ils
vous disent vous êtes élitiste en 2010
les choses voilà quelques secondes à la
cup moi je vais l'entendre tous les
jours partout
est-ce que je posais une question
indiscrète
d'intentions de vote
déjà deux de l'élection en elle-même
pour vous elle a du sens la défense a
nié vous pensez qu'elle est ouverte on a
le sentiment parce que riche en or à la
cada citoyenneté ou même à la cata
combat déclin je venais on a senti les
artichauts je monte à dire là
s'expriment
à 15 h avec l'expression aller se
rappeler un changement donc si ces
verrues
et voilà parce que c'est un sentiment
là maniable
la tendance est ce que vous êtes pour
que monsieur voulait pas continuer son
travail ou là pour que cette équipe par
là on est pour le changement le
changement le changement un ado sans
citer non là bien sûr on est pour le
changement
vous savez que la vie une tradition de
gauche
partis
n'ont parlé de rabaisser vite ni vous
tenez à votre idéal qu'ils ont voté
non non mais chez des mâles mais pour
cette fois ces métadonnées élections
législatives comme neuf
salles faudra appeler de tanger pour 1
[Musique]
j'ai pas là
m
un
tabou
conscientiser
[Musique]
président
malige était à bout de
souffle
il
est
malade
[Musique]
richard
dunne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et surtout il faut que les gens du front
de mourir c'est un vendeur c'est ça
après tu peux pas leur dire
ce qui va se passer pas seulement un
parent qui
devait faire pour le moment je sais que
je vais pas terminée comme étant pas
apparemment c'était le
nom mais je sais que tu n'as pas que ça
hier j'ai dû fermer j'ai dû faire un
portable c'est bon ça je trouve libertin
d'appel
c'est juste infernale et puis au bout
d'un moment tu sais même pas enfin
tu as du mal à trouver les mots justes
moi pourquoi ne pas donner un avis
oui
oui ça va passer avec
c'est
[Musique]
mieux
[Rires]
[Musique]
niedermayer m mais bon ce parce que tout
de toute question de tout commentaire
[Musique]
c'est un score à la soviétique
souvient qu'il a je pense qu'on attend
du verre
ah
parce qu'on va être le modem on
va revenir à nos ouvertures addict à les
déchiffrer le nom fait le
[Rires]
non le titre
vous tournez pas et lui
vaut toutes les races élu dans un
fauteuil
oui
ces affronts
on est la risée du monde
je ne sais pas mais méritoire à
rassembler par la boutique n'est pas son
nom
[Musique]
les numéros pour en faire un geste qui
donc finalistes et gagnantes et à l'udc
genève ne tient pas dans les tuyaux a
donné un non
mais tu n'es pas convaincu mais ce que
je n'en
[Musique]
fais comment ça je crois qu'on est tous
pareils mais c'est juste que je dis
normalement c'est
parce que tu fais un geste en appel qui
ont fait ça tout
tu me demandes atteint jeu
je le fais mais comment qui
y est écrit on les attend mais à tort et
bien ce qui va prendre le jeu ne sais
pas je viens à pont du sartel veut nous
mais on ne sait pas alors que tu n'es
pas sérieux
malgré ça se passe et je marchais le
modèle je pense que ballack à des
réactions à chaud tout de suite c'est
pas déjà pas de me suivre une
déclaration politique
excellent à des rixes aux quatre anneaux
a donné à son nez non c'est pas possible
on s'attendait à quelque chose mais là
ça dépasse une grande erreur
et a peut-être des gens qui ont pensé un
petit peu comme moi vous là comme toi
mais les péniches on va les faire parler
tu n'es pas d'accord et
je pense qu'il ya des gens qui
souhaitent réagir dans ce deal qui est
sage moi je suis sûr qu'ils sont
toujours aussi qu'il
faut que dans les deux mois 90 mn en
ville et non de celle d'un siècle
lorsque la caissière
non mais attends puisqu'elle va pas le
concert qu'il n'a pas entendu pas
maintenant il ya une réaction à chaud
temps par apport des le mode d'élection
que par rapport aux résultats annoncés
ya ensuite des personnes étaient portées
comme les observateurs qui ne sont pas
forcément dans des partis politiques
mais qui ont comme tu l'as dit mourad
[Musique]
qui ont montré de l'intérêt ces gens là
ils sont nombreux qui les connaît pas ça
dépendra bien si tu veux
pas je sais pas battre est-ce que tu te
remets ce que tu penses que physiquement
je ne peux faire à je peux pas encore
répondre pendant une heure appelé
ces personnalités et 12 partis
politiques
monsieur je viens de voir il vient te
voir tu viens mais
je ne suis pas abattu d'accord
je vais le faire mais c'est pas ça je
voulais juste me concerter avec vous qui
serez l'heure quelles sont les
personnalités est il des
importante a fait réagir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce fêtard il déclare ne pas reconnaître
l'élection de mon frère a neuf les
cheveux fédérer de contestataires
de mécontentement populaire le me
contemple comme ça devienne langue pour
les piétons la viande
ça dépend de l'angle régit le système
c'est un constat mais lui veut les
combatifs une fille lisse et combatif
dans ce combat futur où il veut il veut
rassembler tout le monde
il appelle à un rassemblement si sage
éclair les forces politiques mineurs
qu'on n'est pas la victoire de la
carrière où il combat c'est de longue
haleine s'est construit
en première version et on verra dans ces
moments là
c'est pas terminé quoi
[Musique]
et
je me suis dit
[Musique]
non
[Rires]
je
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
on